here is Governor DeSantis calling out
Trump this is just in the last couple
days for being weak when it came to
fauci
and to me leadership is
courage to make difficult decisions in
the teeth of opposition and criticism a
leader must have the confidence to stand
all alone if need be and so for us as I
got into office kovid presented that
situation for us because we were in a
situation the third largest state in the
country one of the highest percentage of
elderly Economy based on tourism which
we needed travel to continue so this
situation was an existential threat to
our state but I made the Judgment
leaders take the bull by the horns and
make the decisions for themselves they
don't subcontract out their leadership
to health bureaucrats like Dr fauci
okay clear honest good now you might
watch that and again I'm really trying
guys I hope you can see it you might
watch that and go maybe DeSantis would
have been bamboozled by those guys too
and that is absolutely true but he
learned in real time real fast and
that's worth acknowledging Trump seems
to not have learned because he refuses
to uh look back at any of his statements
and say I screwed that thing up right
DeSantis very quickly after doing
lockdowns on the rest of it came around
and started doing the right thing
DeSantis actually spent the last couple
days the weekend he was over in Utah and
obviously you know this Trump thing is
heating up so he uh mentioned something
well it's Loosely on Trump and the
culture War
Republicans need to shake the culture of
losing that is developed in recent years
the time for excuses is over we must get
it done if we as Republicans provide a
fresh vision for American Revival then
Republicans will win all across the
country okay it's it's clear and it's
clean if we fight appropriately if we
don't let this culture War always
encroach on us but we use power
cleanly and clearly and effectively and
when it should be used we actually might
do something
[Music]